foreign
[Music]
Welcome to our session
thank you
welcome uh to our session on uh driving
growth through data Innovation um I have
to say I'm actually blown away I mean
wow there's so many people in the room
here it shows I think what a Hot Topic
this is right now and I think that's
because of a convergence of things like
you know platforms like bigquery with
the emergence of data ecosystems that
enable people to share data much more
easily combined with some of the recent
developments in Ai and particularly
generative AI that really created this
kind of Perfect Storm of opportunity and
of innovation that so many people are
interested in
so I have to confess when we were
putting this session together we
considered making it a partner only
session that all the speakers here today
are partners of Google clouds they're
software companies and I'm so glad we
didn't because when I look at the
attendee list there's a whole bunch of
folks here from many other Industries
which is great and if you wouldn't mind
I'd like to do a quick show of hands who
here is from an isv or a data provider
okay and who here is from what I would
consider a customer another industry you
know banking or retail or something else
wow so by far the majority of you folks
aren't in the software business which is
fantastic I think there's gonna be an
awful lot that you can learn from some
of these leaders um that we have on
stage today
so my name is Tom I lead a team called
built with bigquery
um here at Google clouds and I have the
absolute pleasure and privilege of
working with and learning from some of
the most Innovative companies on the
planet in fact they're about over a
thousand now of these B2B SAS companies
and data providers who work and build
their products on top of bigquery and
Google's Ai and data cloud
including 70 of the Gen AI unicorns that
we hear so much about these days
so for those who don't know what the
built with bigquery team is we do two
things we try to accelerate Innovation
and monetization and product development
with our partners by sharing knowledge
and best practices that we've gleaned
working with Partners all over the world
the second thing we do is we highlight
and we showcase those successes through
things like blog posts and events like
this so it's it's a real honor today to
host these guys and enable them to share
their knowledge and their experiences
with all of you and hopefully create an
opportunity for you to learn and the
conversation that will extend well
beyond this session
So today we're going to do a couple of
things we're going to look at some of
the key patterns that we see when
working with isvs and data providers all
around the globe
and then we're going to spend as much
time as we can actually talking to some
of those isos and data providers those
leaders in this field so that we can
hear their stories and you can learn
from their experience
so before we do that let me in the
moment to Define what I think of as data
monetization
um I think of it as the Art and Science
of turning data into value
and so you might be wondering why is
that necessary why do we need to
transform data to make it valuable
surely data is inherently valuable
and I think there's a you know there's a
common misconception perhaps that that
is true you know there's a it's a cliche
at this point that data is a valuable
resource you know whether it be oil or
sand or any of the other analogies that
you may have heard of
like any analogy these these analogies
aren't perfect but one thing they all
have in common is the idea that as a
resource data needs to be transformed
into something of value right it needs
to be turned into a product to some
description
so when I think of monetization I think
of productization I think really those
two terms are synonymous
so what do I mean by that what do we
mean by a productizing data
so first and foremost of course you have
to have
a process for developing that product
right you have to have a development
process that ensures it's fresh it's
accurate it's tested do you have all of
the things that you would have with any
other software product you need to have
a roadmap so that you can ensure that
you're continuing to give value to your
customers as it evolves of course you
need to have a way of Distributing it to
get it into the hands of your customers
but perhaps more importantly it needs to
provide some value to customers and this
sounds obvious right but so often it's
overlooked you know the idea that you
have a great data set people are
automatically going to consume it just
doesn't bear
um you know bear reality
so focusing on the value that it
provides to your customers but also of
course it needs to provide value to you
as a data provider a product that
doesn't provide value to you isn't going
to have a very long life cycle as a
product or a very long roadmap and there
are a couple of ways of doing that
through direct or indirect monetization
which is really where we're going to
spend our time today
so just to unpack those Concepts a
little further
often overlooked in this whole thing is
the idea of indirect monetization it's
incredibly important to manifests in all
sorts of different ways so basically
it's about creating increased
differentiation increased usage increase
stickiness of your product through the
provision of these data products within
it so
be in the form of helping you to acquire
more customers or be more effective in
converting those customers from
prospects because of the additional
products that you're providing it could
be that it helps to improve things like
retention and engagement and adoption
within your customers because you're
providing new capabilities they may not
have had before that make certain
classes of users much more engaged with
the product you have already you know a
good example is perhaps an e-commerce
vendor who has a platform
providing information about how that
platform is performing you know how it's
converting customers throughout the
shopping cycle is a really valuable way
of providing additional value to those
customers over and above simply the act
of providing the e-commerce platform it
may provide a competitive
differentiation so that it helps you to
compete more effectively when you're in
a head-to-head with some of your
competitors
importantly it can be a way of proving
value to your customers again in the
e-commerce example
you might launch a new feature that
enables you to a B test two different
flows
by by allowing the customer to
understand the difference that you're
making and the conversion rate you're
proving the value that this additional
feature has provided to them and
therefore the value that they get from
subscribing to your product so
incredibly important way of proving
value and also and this relates more to
the the data sharing ecosystems but the
idea that you can create increased go to
market alignment so if you're talking to
for example a Google seller one of the
field sales reps here for a customer the
fact that you're sharing data with their
customer which generates additional
consumption within their tenant is a
great reason to have a conversation
often overlooked it's one of the
benefits here
so of course the most obvious way that
you monetize is directly and there are a
number of ways that you can think about
this as well for example you know one of
the decisions that you'll need to make
is whether you're going to bundle this
additional feature within the core
product or perhaps an additional tier
for example you know your basic version
may not have a data product attached to
it but the pro version may do and the
Enterprise version may have an even
greater level of capability that you
provide to them all you can have is a
standalone product something that you
sell independently of the main product
as cross-sell or an upsell you've got to
think about things like how do you want
to charge for it is it a subscription is
it pay as you go do you do even a
Perpetual license and how do you think
about that do you provide a flat rate
do you pay per user per month you do it
based on usage how much consumption how
much data they're scanning how much data
they're storing
Etc
another important way that you can
monetize with directly with customers is
by opening up new user groups within
that organization so for example there
might be a whole team of analysts and
data scientists within your customer
base that doesn't have a reason to use
the product right now they don't need to
buy a license but by adding in these
additional capabilities you might open
up a whole new area of analysts and data
scientists who can't wait to get their
hands on the data but haven't had the
opportunity to until this point
and then lastly of course you can use
the expertise that you've built working
with many customers across your industry
across your vertical to provide
Professional Services to them Consulting
to help optimize what they're doing
using the data you're providing to them
to be even more effective using your
products
the key thing to highlight here of
course is that these products these
approaches aren't mutually exclusive you
will combine them you will choose to
bundle some of these capabilities with
your core product offering and you will
choose probably to charge for some of
them separately and that may be a
journey to embark on your first release
may be about giving them additional
value within the product monetizing
indirectly and then it may be that over
time you start to add on more and more
features that become far more valuable
and therefore warrant a separate skew
so when we work with all of these
Partners we've come to identify a range
of different patterns that people use
high level patterns that we see over and
over and again and these are the ways
that
these guys are using a platform to drive
additional value additional monetization
so I'm going to break these down for you
effectively you think of these as nine
tried and tested way of driving
additional value or driving additional
monetization
of course is the idea of an analytics a
data analytics as a service all of these
products to some extent rely on the idea
of having a data set that you can query
that you can explore that you can gain
Insight from
in addition to that we see two types of
additional pattern the first
is what we think of as core application
patterns so these are where you're
adding additional capability onto that
core analytics data set and the other
type really relates to something just
more recent which is the data sharing
ecosystem so taking the data out of the
core application and sharing either
directly with the customer or to some
other third party
so first of those is what we think of as
embedded AI now we're not going to cover
this particular Topic in too much detail
today and the reason for that is because
there is an excellent session tomorrow
that this focuses exclusively on this
but this use case is really about the
idea of
um layering on top of that analytics
that data analytics application that
you've developed and using it to drive
far more far richer data experiences now
of course we have the looker product
which is ideally suited to this it
enables visualization through charts and
other visual elements but also things
like alerts and it provides a common
what we call a semantic layer that sits
on top of these data sources so you can
integrate with things like bigquery you
can integrate with other data sources
that you have and create this Rich
visualization bi layer which is embedded
within your product so a really fast and
easy way of driving additional value
using effectively the same
infrastructure that you have today
the second of these is what we think of
as alphabet Integrations there are a
couple of these that we see over and
over again one of them is integrating
with Google marketing Cloud Google
marketing platform so things like ads
and Google analytics Etc and you can
hear some of our speakers talk about
that today the other area we see an
awful lot of this is integrating with
Earth engine our geospatial partners our
sustainability partners are huge users
of this capability but there are many
others things like integrating with
merchant center if you're an e-commerce
vendor integrating your Merchant catalog
so real Rich opportunity there and very
unique to Google these are opportunities
that just aren't as easy if you're
running on a different Cloud if you're
not using bigquery it's a really
powerful way a very quickly delivering
additional value
the next
of course Ai and ml
a year ago I would probably have been
standing here talking about the powerful
predictive capabilities of AI and ml
today most of the conversations we have
inevitably about generative Ai and it's
power to generate but whatever the story
is this is an incredibly important way
of you driving additional value for your
customers using the data that you have
and then lastly in the core aggregate
the core application use cases is what
we think of as activation you know so
often we provide information to users
some organizations we work with take
that further and they actually use that
information to drive activity to drive
action within the application itself and
again some of our partners are going to
talk about this today
so if we switch over to the other side
and we talk about some of these data
sharing use cases the first of those
that we think of is what we call the
data twin and what we mean by that is
that you might be an isv again I go back
to my analogy or my example of the the
Commerce vendor who is uh sharing the
customer they have customer data right
they have a whole bunch of information
about transaction and sales and that
type of thing the customer finds that
data really valuable and they want to
combine it with the rest of their data
estate they might have CRM data they
might have inventory data and they want
to bring it all together so it can
create that 360 degree view of their
supply chain of their customer Etc and
so we can do that through a number of
ways these days a lot of what we do is
in product codes analytics Hub which
enables them to share without copying
that data into the customer's bigquery
instance very very easily
the next is really an extension of that
and we've seen this much more in the
last couple of months has been really
growing which is the idea of a data
cleaning room so when you start to share
data particularly around customers Etc
but sometimes related to supply chains
you need to be able to share private
data sets securely in a way that enables
multiple parties to look at just the
amount of data that is appropriate for
them to you know one of the examples
that's often given is a retailer who
wants to share Coca-Cola statistics with
Coke and Pepsi statistics with Pepsi but
doesn't want to share the other way
around so you can create a data clean
room to do that equally if you're doing
marketing and you want to gain access to
some additional information about a
customer but without sharing pii data
you can use a data clean room so a
really powerful way of augmenting the
data twin use case and something that
was just announced this week at a Google
Cloud next
so the next of these is what we think of
as data publisher and we've got Dan and
Bradstreet with us today who are you
know a fantastic Exemplar of this but
this is different to data twin in that
rather than sharing the customers data
back with them
these are organizations that are sharing
data sets that are proprietary to them
the corpuses of data that they've
curated refined and made available to
customers uh to buy and so really
powerful use case there and something
that may resonate with many of you if
you're
sitting on valuable data that you may
choose to to do something with
I think it was Data warehouses service
so this is where you are sharing
um
your customer wants to do more they want
to be able to perhaps do some more
detailed analysis they might have have a
need for reports that you can't provide
and they may want to even bring in their
own data it's a very simple way of that
is doing that is to create a project for
them to deploy bigquery perhaps even put
some looker in there to deploy data
that's useful to them and then give them
access so you're providing really a
fully functional very rich data
warehouse experience but without having
to uh for them to become a Google Cloud
customer it resides in your tenancy so
those are the nine patterns that we
that we work with here within the built
with bigquery team and it is now my
pleasure to welcome on stage my panel of
speakers
who are going to share some of their
experience with
welcome Andy and Lee
and Spencer and Aaron
so
to get us started I'm going to ask you
each to just introduce yourself to spend
a minute or so telling who you are and
who you know a little bit about your
company so start with you Andy all right
well thank you Tom and Google Cloud for
hosting this and everyone attending I'm
Annie scree VP of product at exabeam
security operations platform we help
large organizations defect detect defend
and defeat attacks that start both
internally and externally we do this by
delivering a modular platform that helps
us meet organizations where they are in
their maturity Journey this typically
starts with Cloud scale security log
management being able to ingest a large
amount of data making it available for
search reporting and detection we can
layer on additional capabilities like
our Advanced AI based Behavior analytics
that normalizes and learns the behavior
of every user and device to identify
anomalies to root out threats and
finally we offer automation so
organizations can automate the full
threat detection investigation and
response life cycle for more consistent
and repeatable security outcomes
thank you thank you hi everyone I'm Lee
Luxembourg from dun and Bradstreet I
manage co-innovation with Google cloud
and we've seen a lot of that since we've
started our partnership done and
Bradstreet started 180 something years
ago as a business credit agency and soon
realized that the underlying data for
that business credit and the sources
that it came from was value of itself
and the insights that came of it so we
since then quickly realized we will
create you know data as a product and be
able to sell that as value for customers
but also fuel SAS offerings in spaces of
sales and marketing third-party risk and
compliance and also Master data
management for customers across all
sizes
great I'm Spencer Pingree head-up
software architecture for optimizely
optimizely is a suite of products built
for marketers and developers to deliver
personalize and optimize experiences we
do this through kind of three main sets
of products one is content so everything
to do with content from ideation
collaboration creation and delivery the
second is Commerce with our configured
Commerce products for B2B and b2c and
then the last which I'm going to spend
all the time talking about today is our
experimentation products which are for
web experimentation for on-site and
encode and feature experimentation for
flag based experimentation
thanks Vince
and I'm Aaron bulkins I am a VP of
product at live ramp and live ramp is
the partner of choice for identity
driven data collaboration for the
world's most Innovative companies we
help companies really understand their
customers through the power of data and
we help them interact with their
customers and and guide the customer
Journey
ending in the best results for both them
and their and their customers
thank you Aaron
so let's jump into the the conversation
so by now you're all familiar with this
uh this model I want to start off with
really the core of this and Andy and Lee
it'd be great to hear from you Andy
you've always been built on bigquery
um Lee you've you've decided to move
there more recently in the last couple
of years so I'd love to hear from both
of you about why you made that decision
and and how it's worked out for you so
perhaps starting with you Andy yeah
absolutely we we started our journey
with bigquery about two and a half years
ago exabeam started out as an on-premise
appliance-based company and so when we
wanted to make that re-platforming shift
to Cloud we we chose bigquery and there
were two primary use cases that we were
really looking to solve first is we
wanted to make sure that we were able to
have a platform level data store so we
could collect normalize all of the data
once and then monetize that data
multiple times through different
applications and insights that we
provide one of those primary drivers was
our security analytics capability so we
needed a bigquery or a data store that
could scale to drive the detection
capabilities that our customers expect
we offer multiple different analytics
engines and actually yesterday we were
named the tech partner of the year for
security analytics from Google Cloud
so that was a big driver for us was that
platform data store secondly was our
ability to give our customers access to
that data store to query it during
security investigations and there were a
number of really key use cases there one
is we needed customers to have the
ability to ingest all of the data that
they cared about they needed to be able
to retain that data for up to 10 years
based on compliance and investigation
needs and they need to be able to access
that data at scale quickly when you're
doing a security investigation you have
a breach you can't afford to run a query
and wait 30 minutes both for data that
just came in and that data that's 10
years old
we also needed to make sure that
customers had the ability to craft
complex queries access and the the right
insights and aggregate that data
the last one we needed was we needed to
make sure that the solution scaled based
on the access on demand when you're in
an incident or a breach you may have 10x
the number of queries and people using
that service we need to make sure that
service is highly available when our
customers need it the most uh bigquery
was the choice for us it's really been
delighting our customers in terms of the
applications we're delivering and it's
helped our engineering team deliver new
features and applications much faster
without having to worry about where do I
get the data how do I format it and
manage the data life cycle
thank you Andy Lee and for us I mean
much like Andy's response you know
security infrastructure and scale is
important for Dunham Bradstreet not only
our 180 years of data but you know
business information for over 525
million companies across the globe and
so having one place where all that
information can work together and
efficiently with something that we
haven't had in a long time and really a
big driver in our decision to move not
just our data but all of our platforms
to Google cloud in doing so we are able
to fuel our products our data our SAS
offerings our models for the our
customers that use our data so much more
efficiently and consistently and without
the data latency issues and just finding
that as we you know continue to migrate
and make everything you know consistent
in one place where the customers are
already reaching out to us to say
clearly things are they're better
they're faster they're cleaner you know
thank you so much and so it's a great
partnership we have at Google Cloud
fantastic thank you Lee so in order to
save us a bit of time here I only group
some of these categories together
because some of them there's some
overlap here and so I want to start off
with you Spencer and to talk about a
couple of things you know I know you
have some deep Integrations with Google
Cloud Google marketing Cloud
um but also by Design you know from day
one you particularly with the products
you're talking about today you've always
taken action within those products that
by Design so I'd love you to talk a
little bit more about that
uh yeah so part of experimentation is
always affecting the experience so we
always
um any output of a result an experiment
is always a change in action for the
experience of the user
um so that action and activation is part
of kind of our core product as it
relates to Integrations into the broader
alphabet anybody that's dealt with
marketing or martech industry knows you
always get the question how does this
compare to Google analytics and how do
you how do you integrate better with
AdWords and analytics and and kind of
that stack
and so two things that we've been doing
which kind of on the back end through
bigquery has really helped facilitated
is with Google analytics we can now kind
of get common reporting across the two
products so that you can view experiment
results within Google analytics and then
coming soon is also the ability to take
audiences design defined in Google
analytics and activate them directly
through experimentation and so that
those audiences that you define we can
deliver all the way through to the
experience and measure the output of
those experiments
um and maybe the last call I'll make
just because it's relevant at the moment
is Google a year ago also decided to
Sunset a product called Google optimize
which we've been helping migrate a lot
of customers over to if you're on Google
optimize you have about four weeks to
move off so feel free to sales pitch
feel free to find somebody with an
optimizely badge and we're happy to help
you uh finish that migration absolutely
so Erin you mentioned that you are the
platform of choice for data
collaboration and so inherently you're
integrating with other systems there do
you want to say a little bit more about
how that works for you
yeah absolutely we have really deep
Integrations with the Google marketing
platform virtually all of our all of
live ramp products are available through
the marketing platform
and it really Smooths the transition and
eases customer onboarding by making it
making available to patterns that many
customers are used to available for our
products as well and not only does is
there onboarding and purchasing
experience smoother but they're able to
optimize not only budgets but resources
when it comes to operating through the
Google platform with live ramp products
and the fact that you're hosted on
Google clouds and you're integrating
with Google products creates an enormous
amount of benefits associated with that
right because it's all in the same place
absolutely as everyone anyone knows like
the more consolidation you can do with
your data the easier it is to transact
on that data and to have full visibility
across your entire
data product Suite on um what's going on
in your organization and one of the
things that we offer is identity
resolution which can break down those
data silos and give you a true as you
were saying 360 view across all of your
data especially people-based data so
that you can understand
how your customer is interacting with
you no matter what channel it's through
so Andy I know that you're on a journey
um with your product suite and how
driving active action off the back of
that data is super important you want to
say a little bit about how you're
driving activation through exopine yeah
you know in security operations it's not
enough for us to detect threats and
highlight insights organizations need
that closed-loop experience for
remediation and action most
organizations have upwards of 70
different security products deployed
that oftentimes don't talk to each other
and are not integrated they look for
Solutions like access beam to integrate
those pieces together and Google Cloud
offers us a lot of pre-built
Integrations into common components from
a security perspective to allow us to
drive that action and close that Loop a
lot faster
fantastic thank you
so on a switch now to the other side of
these patterns which is the data sharing
patterns and and everyone on stage here
is doing something in space so I'm going
to pick on a just a subset of folks here
to talk about what they're doing and I
think Lee I want to start with you
because obviously at the heart of what
Dunham Bridge Street does is share data
and I know you've recently started
adopting analytics Hub as a product so
I'd love to hear you talk more about
that sure so this is the other half of
the why right why Google Cloud because
of the ecosystem and the publishing
support and opportunity to really
monetize their data as Tom mentioned
earlier both indirectly and directly so
by this transformational world where
file sharing is different than it was
before you know delivering files to
customers is it's a different story
everyone's in the cloud they want their
data in the cloud as much of you do so
by Able by us being able to put our data
in bigquery share via analytics help
create this catalog of our data
offerings that we can publish make it
you know apparent and obvious of what we
have have to have customers efficiently
receive our data through through a
bigquery in a structured and consistent
way also again reducing that latency
issue to reduce their risk making sure
their data is more up to date it's just
kind of opened up a new Avenue for us
for not just delivery but being a
partner with Google Cloud sales and
marketing opportunities through
analytics Hub being able to get our name
and information out there to what we do
and how we can support customers kind of
add the layer on top of that for
monetization now the data Marketplace
the Google cloud data sorry Google Cloud
Marketplace being able to sell data
there we're able to help customers who
want to procure through Marketplace
spend use commitment they may have and
make it easier to go ahead and procure
the data and obviously ingest it so it's
kind of comes full circle for us as a
data publisher
it's been a real pleasure to be on that
Journey with you as well as we started
to see the transformation that's made
absolutely so Spencer I think I used you
as an example earlier about how somebody
may want to
take the rich data that you have and
leverage it in their own data warehouse
their own context could you say
something about you know how your
customers use that and how you help them
provide value like that yeah I think a
lot of our largest customers have entire
practices built around experimentation
so they'll have uh teams I think much
like Andy mentioned earlier and
mentioned about the um the teams wanting
to get the the data back so they can do
what they need to do to drive more uses
of that data across their organization
and experimentation they may have teams
that that manage 10 experiments at a
time and some that are managing hundreds
or thousands of experiments at a time
and so the ability to use that data join
it to their data sets within their
systems and and create a more a wider
array of experiments or more relevant
experiments is something that's really
important for us to be able to get that
data that we've collected and share it
back to our organization so that they
can do what they need to do with it to
leverage it across their their teams
so lastly Aaron there's a couple of
things here isn't it there's the data
clean room so think I mean data sharing
is the heart of what you facilitate so
talk a little bit of data sharing but
also I'd be interested to you to say a
little bit about data warehouses servers
you're really one of the Pioneers with
that use case now it's driven value for
you
yeah that's right we uh we do Drive data
collaboration in the ecosystem and we
are a privacy-centric company and so in
order to do that safely we have a couple
of tools in our tool belt one of them is
data clean rooms that we bring the
customers data in be a two or
three-party data and allow them to join
that data in a safe and effective manner
manner through our identity resolution
inside the clean room we also work with
a lot of companies that kind of span the
Spectrum on the maturity that the
technology and Cloud maturity spectrum
and so some companies need help need
help managing their identity need help
managing their data and so what we can
do for them is we can establish an
environment in our tenancy and set up
their data set up their systems apply
identity and basically they have a ready
to go first party data strategy using
this this data warehouse as a service
and it really made makes things smooth
easy and and easy to get up and running
in their their collaboration strategy
and does that enable you to provide
additional Professional Services to them
to help guide them as well as the
software you're helping them to evolve
their strategy using your expertise Etc
yeah that's right we offer Professional
Services because we know that things in
the data industry aren't always
self-serve and easy to do
especially when it comes to our deep
industry expertise and identity we can
offer Consulting on like how to build
the identity strategy for your business
goals and having access to the data and
having an environment in our tenancy
allows really fast iteration because we
don't have to go back and forth and ask
for permission and and it has all the
tools at our disposal in order to make
progress really really fast fantastic
so lastly of these patterns
um is is perhaps one of the most
interesting and significant at the
moment which is of course the use of AI
and ML and having worked with all of you
I know that this is a Hot Topic in your
organizations many of you have been
using this type of technology for many
years but have gained some recent
impetus as a result of early emergence
of some of these new models his
architectures his capabilities so I'll
start with you Andy and go along I'd
like you each to talk about how perhaps
where you are today and where you're
looking to go in the future
yeah as you mentioned we've been using
AI from the very beginning to try to
help detect threats and behaviors but
gender of AI is a really interesting
space now for us for a number of
different reasons one of the key things
from a Google partnership perspective is
Google's one of the only companies that
offers a commercial commercially
available llm focused on cyber security
and that's really important for me is
having that security expertise built
into an llm that we can start to
leverage and productize for our
customers with that right level of
context
from what are we looking at there's a
number of things first is we want to
help our customers be able to secure
their own llms that they're developing
in-house through our platform and the
other big area is how do we help with
these cyber security Talent shortage by
really offering new Innovative features
that can help train new Cyber Security
Professionals on the job help them
understand what they're looking at
derive new insights that they may not
know to to really accelerate their
ability to understand the problems that
they're looking at both all the way down
in the sock from an analyst perspective
we also look on the flip side what does
a CSO need in terms of being able to
talk to the board of directors when it
comes to specific cyber incidents and
threats it's a different talk track and
different level of detail than an
analyst needs even if it's the same
threat so how do you extrapolate how do
you use generated AI to tell both sides
of that story so really excited about
the partnership we have with Google to
start to deliver some of these
capabilities across our platform
Donna Bradshaw is excited to announce
this week our our partnership in
generative AI going forward and first
being vertex I vertex AI being a
foundational technology in our AI lab
and this is a place where our customers
come and develop applications and models
using our data that help them support
obviously their business whether it be
understanding who they should go after
after first sales and marketing
perspective or who they can or should do
business with for third party risk
suppliers and vendors
we provide a lot of data we provide a
lot of insights we have we have a lot of
data science behind it but also using AI
to make that information more more
understandable more readable for
companies to really know who are they
working with should they be working with
them and then even creating the the
linkage of who are these businesses and
who are they connected to so that being
really the first AI use case we're
starting with as well as using our data
for ourselves and for our customers to
fuel these automated chat agents that
can help provide information across you
know obviously a number of data sets so
easily and so conversationally without
having to have you know teams of people
behind the scenes providing that
information so we're excited for those
first two and look forward to many more
with Google cloud and I think that's
such a sometimes overlooked aspect of of
generative and large language models in
general you know we're all familiar with
the the well-known models of course in
Google and others but that data is
largely trained on publicly available
information across the web Etc but
there's an enormous amount of incredibly
valuable data that's private to
companies that spent 180 years creating
that data making it valuable and so the
ability to expose that information
through a large language model is
incredibly powerful and we're really
excited to be working with you to help
make that happen
Spencer oh yeah I'll probably talk about
two things one is as a company that has
content there's obvious use cases that
that we uh are excited about as it
relates to the content generation side
but also having so much data about user
experience I think we're really
interested in how do we think about data
products internally and then map them
across the the suite of our products and
so that we can we can apply these models
not just in a specific point use case
but really with the context of our
clients across all of our products
through the types of content they create
the types of users they have the
segments that they have that interact
with their content as well and so we're
we're spending a lot of time trying to
focus on those use cases as we get
through the kind of maybe the more
standard ones that we've seen come out
and then I'd just say internally you
know the space is changing rapidly to
say the least and so we're we're
thinking a lot about how do we reduce
the friction for adoption for our
product teams because we have multiple
products and Ai and data science and ml
as in centralized in a single team
necessarily anymore it's really spread
out across the company and so how do we
provide the tools to our engineers and
our product people and the training to
enable them to move as quickly as this
industry is going and so Google's been
actually a great partner in helping us
both enable those through things like
the open source models and vertex and
then also having training available for
our for our engineers
thank you Smith and then last but by
name means Lise Aaron
uh yeah so everything that we do is in
service of helping our customers
understand their customers and their
prospects better and one of the assets
that we we have and we facilitate is is
a really good first party data strategy
and we also have an identity graph and
one of the things we've been using for a
long time we've used several different
deep learning methodologies over the
years but one of the ones that we
continue to harken back to is the
Transformer architecture something I
think that you're pretty familiar with
considering that Google invented it
um and so we've used this uh this deep
learning methodology for a while and it
really is accredited with uh with the
success of generative AI today but
continuing to use the tools available to
us through Google and other uh in our
own algorithms we're able to continue to
continually Drive accuracy and match
rates in our graph which affects
literally every product in our company
uh the better we can connect the data in
the ecosystem the better we can help
companies understand every touch point
in the customer Journey the more
successful they'll be for their business
outcomes and so AI is helping pave the
way fantastic thank you and I know that
also of course all of your customers are
looking at this space as well and of
course they're looking to join together
the data sets that they have to create
that 360 degree view so you can take
advantage of these new capabilities I
know live ramp are really at the center
of that and helping organizations like
dun and Bradstreet and optimizely become
part of ecosystem a way where you
understand who a customer is who are
business is and you can join those
together so yeah absolutely like I was
saying the more we're able to connect
those data points the more we can drive
Revenue through data monetization
because the more we're able to match the
data with with Partners through
collaboration the better results for
everyone fantastic
so that's a quick walkthrough of the
models of the patterns that we use
we're out of time now if you have any
further questions if you want to follow
up please reach out to me tomcannon
google.com I'll be outside we need to
leave this room relatively promptly but
before I close I'll just say a couple of
things firstly there are a few great
sessions I would highly encourage you to
attend first of all if you're interested
in the embedded bi session topic there
is a great session by colleague of our
scander tomorrow at 11 30 I highly
recommend you look at that we'll go much
deeper into some of the direct and
indirect monetization models really
knowledgeable uh guy thoroughly
recommend this session there's also
another session tomorrow around the
partner Advantage Program if you're
looking to become part of that and you
can use capabilities like a Google cloud
ready bigquery program to to monetize
Integrations that type of thing an
excellent session A Partners here today
exabeam have a topic tomorrow at quarter
five uh sorry today a quarter five
this session has already been yesterday
I attended it it was excellent uh so you
can see that on demand and then there
are a whole bunch of other partners
geotab faraday.ai and Atlas AI all of
whom part of built with bigquery we work
with really closely if you do get a
chance please stop by their sessions
because you'll learn a lot and they're
really Innovative partners
and last but not least we'd love to have
your feedback please just take a minute
or two to tell us what you think you
know it helps us to improve and it helps
us to decide whether a similar session
like this will be valuable again in the
future and it really does help us to
improve so with that I'll just say thank
you to you thank you to the panel really
enjoyed this session today and I hope
you have too so and enjoy the rest of
next
thank you
[Music]
foreign